the most important page in the book is
always the table of contents because it
tells you what's the content inside the
book it also shows you how they organize
the thinking process and if you're like
well I kind of really understand this
stuff already I'm going to just go to
the part that I don't understand I want
to learn more about your value per
second self-imposed on a book can go way
up and then if they totally blow you out
of the water with the thing that you're
most interested on then you can start
working your way down what was my second
most important third most important
fourth most important and then the
moment the value per second becomes more
redundant on stuff you already know then
it's like well if my fifth most
important thing I already knew a lot
about and the rest of the stuff I'm less
interested in then I maximize the value
of the book for me